[Music]
and not what it seems news submitted by
Bob lob inspirational speaker Tony
Robinson's is being accused of grouping
multiple women and mistreating his
vulnerable followers with punishment
great Tony Robbins or Robinson Robbins
ok wait does a nice guy Tony and Robin
so he's a creep yeah he's a creep
BAM he's been popular for a long did you
do it's a motivational speaker like
inspirational whatever I gotta hear more
details cuz like yeah he he's like a
really really big he's huge
vulnerable women sounds like the women
who like are like heartbroken and stuff
you know so this is a five part BuzzFeed
news investigation BuzzFeed okay now it
must be legit so they have this they did
this really really in-depth
investigation because it all started
with Tony Robbins head of security he
approached them saying like hey you know
what she's actually pretty [ __ ] shady
oh I worked for him for 25 years and
this is this [ __ ] he's done so what the
[ __ ] was he sexually sexually so he's
claiming this dude he's claiming that
Tony would grope women yeah wait and
wait like just like reach for a titty I
can do this I'm Tony Robin for example
um one of the scenarios is like he would
tell women and like part of his process
is like okay I want you to twist your
nipples and I forgot the term but
something about Tokyo because I can't
twist your nipples and say that term
doesn't even exist that's fine no cool
you gotta watch these things though like
if you watch his actual conventions it's
like he does colleague touch it to like
get you out of your head it's not like
like who touch yourself like this now
like it's not like sexual like that have
you attended one of these that's why I
know about this this context I have a
lot of friends that have gone and then
he had that thing on Netflix where they
actually showed you one of his
conventions and their girls
twisting the nipples no no the one that
I saw but he'll do things to get
specific people out of their head so
like he'll hear your story and then try
to do different exercises to get them
out of their way of thinking and
reprogram you would tell these women to
twist our nipples and say calling Tokyo
as a way of breaking the patterns like
we like it public though or like a whole
note it leaves a vent
yeah in the event it's all private okay
that's not right though you know what
though I feel like when you're in a
vulnerable position and you like pay
someone to change your life you know if
he says like bend over and grab your ass
like I bet you women would do it you
know cuz they're trying to reach for
like that but that's not as crazy as
[ __ ] twisted it don't worry gravity
do most ochio
I'd be curious to know what exactly the
women said like their story was before
he told them to do that cuz it could be
like it could be any sort of thing you
think it's believable you think like
things I don't know yeah I'm kind of
like erring on the side of like I want
more information before making a
judgement because I feel like he does
things that snap you out of your head
that aren't like let's say you have a
bad connotation with sex or sexual
things like doing things that reprogram
you to not you know like another one was
like he told a woman and at an event to
stroke her breasts as a way of getting
back in touch with her feminine side see
that's that's not bad to me at the
beginning we said groping women yeah
yeah that's not the same so I want to
hear about grabbing titties grab that's
what I'm that's exactly what I'm saying
I think that things get twisted around
he's also tried a lot of people I've
tried to get him in trouble in the past
for different practices like he's the
guy that does the walking across hot
coals thing and then like people burned
their feet and then like yeah well
that's also part of the whole thing too
is saying that he's not concerned for
people's safety and like he doesn't
provide enough medical staff and I meant
during his events like the multiple Day
event
he doesn't properly feed people or give
them enough water and like he'd pretty
much deprives them of food to a point
where some people get really delirious
so that's also part of it - let me see
that groping thing but there is also way
more other things where for example in
one of the events he would make people
drink this brown liquid that's
designed to have a lasting effect and
then they'll also put stickers of the
letter L and call them losers if they
weren't able to pay for the next event
that he had oh and like humiliating
tactics you know what they're saying and
so that's another thing that people were
like that's not right I mean he's been
doing this for a long time and I think
that when you are in a position of power
for such a long time you're gonna use it
to your advantage
I don't know you don't think so I don't
know I'd have to hear more information
it's not like I don't believe it I just
need to hear more information because he
just doesn't it's the way that he's been
like in that industry for so long and if
you see his like conventions in the way
that they that he is some people can
call it cheesy I get it but like he's
very like you were like help push the
envelope in ways that like get people to
break them out of their shell like stuff
that like shocks your body in a way
that's like oh [ __ ] like you have to
like mind over matter [ __ ] I don't know
I just think that intention is like
really where it is and so if the
intention is I want to molest somebody
that's way different than like hey get
in touch with your feminine feminine
side by touching your own breasts like
I've had to do that like I was really
out of touch with my feminine side and I
had it I went to like this pole dancing
class that like with all women and it
was like just teaching you how to get
more in touch with your own femininity
and it really really helped and it
opened me up in so many ways so it's not
I don't know just cause he's a guy doing
do guiding it I don't think that's it
because the article said there's a
BuzzFeed investigation into multiple
women claiming he groped them sorry cuz
that's not groping that's why I want to
know more information because if you're
gonna smear something that strong on
someone then I want to know like what
exactly happened look it even made his
own staff uncomfortable yeah staff is
the one going to the media because they
a lot of his staff are volunteers and so
they're not even getting paid they just
get paid by listening to him speak
Tellis genius you get hey
in turn when you normally charge
thousands of dollars a ticket like they
make they probably feel like they so one
of the groping things are in here is how
this one woman in the late nineties
during a job interview he placed his
hand on her knee okay and so she pushed
it away and so that she felt
uncomfortable and he did and he never
did it again okay that's one is that the
worst one I mean it is a little bit
weird like especially during a job
interview like don't touch me you know I
think it's a lot to do when you're what
you're saying when you're in a
vulnerable place and he's this guy of
power it goes both ways - it's not just
one person taking advantage of the power
sometimes people get attached to that
like they see you as daddy or whatever
psychological issues and then when
they're not attached in the same way
it's like what he groped me he did this
he's like sent me signals like that kind
of thing I'm not saying like I can't
comment either way I'm not giving my
opinion on this but I just like to hear
more information because I don't I don't
know like from watching all of his stuff
and reading his books for years and
listening to audio tapes I did all of
that I've studied a lot of Tony Robbins
stuff and I don't think that he comes
across or like and he'll be looking
people could come across different ways
and maybe they're concealing their true
identities I don't know but like to me
it just seems like he's very like all
about empowering and like using mind
over matter and using shock techniques
to get you out of that without being
creepy and without being like well this
is like out of across the line you know
so I'm gonna play a a audio clip of
where Tony he was pretty it just makes
them sound bad so this was provided to
BuzzFeed
[Music]
rapacity they [ __ ] feel you I also
find it about that people don't just act
a certain [ __ ] way
what I find what I usually dig in and I
take the time what they call abuse is a
relabeling up they didn't like what the
person said or did
cuz he loved you is he looked out for
you put up with you been a crazy [ __ ]
if you ever been a great season ever
probably soon this guy be out strung up
and shot what do you discuss and
certainly said that he is not behaving
ways that are great for you but just
know by your body of in your line I know
by the words I don't like the context
that you're lying is nobody is evil
everything over seven years I don't get
what's wrong with yes is it just because
of the way like words of tough love it's
really sounds really hard they're trying
to make it sound like a woman's like I
was abused and he's like that you were
you're alive yeah that's not what he was
saying though I mean that's not what it
sounds like any person that's abused and
any like if I come to you and I tell you
like geo like this happened to me with
my boyfriend you know like I [ __ ] me
up and you're like well did you really
[ __ ] you up if you did you deserve it
deke this is so out of context we don't
know what happened the entire
conversation before this happened this
is just a really bad clip seems like
everything so far that we're hearing is
like times have changed people are the
me to stuff is getting even like smaller
and smaller and smaller too like you
touched my shoulder to like everything
and then now like people just don't like
his attitude and I haven't seen anything
super crazy yet
so like you said it probably will take
more time to see this but yeah I don't
know like I'm not saying all those women
were lying or whatever like I'm just
saying like it just doesn't seem like
there's very much information I mean it
just sounds like I mean I have never
heard him and I have never read any of
his stuff you know so I'm not
emotionally a touch to him I have no
idea what the [ __ ] this guy is you know
but like if you just show someone like
myself that like right here you show me
this you're just getting one side of the
picture
what the [ __ ] this guy's
do you know what I mean but because you
know Hamming you've been listening to
his stuff you're like no like I think
that he means this or you know like
that's why critical thinking has to take
place more in society you can't just
hear one side of a story and be like oh
well that's obviously that there are
monsters like that that's guys a monster
you know you have to tell the truth like
reading this whole BuzzFeed thing to me
it sounded like oh they're making like
really something tiny like the whole
thing like very really to me sounded
exaggerating you guys can read this on
your own yeah but to me it sounded like
it's not that big of a deal and whatever
he did mean I could see how it could be
taken out of context yeah you could take
anything from one of those conventions
way out of context cuz he does like
shocking stuff and that conversation
like if that could have been heavily
edited to where they're just slicing
together like different sentences or
different phrases to make it sound like
one complete thought and it's it's
really [ __ ] up I don't know so the
other two that they were mentioning and
this whole thing is that he would he
would be in the nude and having his
employees come in and like take notes
really quick while he's in the shower
and so for them like there they'd be
like what the [ __ ] were they like hey
can we wait till you're out of the
shower or were they like no that's too
much power so a lot of these people are
like they're anonymous because they're
saying like I'm afraid of retaliation
because he has so much power and like
you know like people believe him and
like they're not gonna believe me I'm
just an employee a volunteer or whatever
well they quit they used to work yeah so
but even though they used to work for
him they're still afraid of him it's
probably painted out and so yeah I mean
like I feel like if it was as big of a
thing like an R kelly thing we would all
know about it already you know and maybe
like by the time this is out or even in
a couple of months you know this will be
bigger but that is kind of where like
imagine if you're like if Joe was taking
a shower and he's like hey can you come
in here and take notes real quick like
that'd be [ __ ] weird okay it just has
to be more in context for me like I
guess like so people showers different
he's Rich's [ __ ] it could be like he's
showering behind the door
you know like that's a separate shower
room and I am behind the door of the
like he was I stood up naked in front of
them in front of them or he was naked
behind the door or whatever you know
like there was because he was naked
front of them that's weird and then
there was another one saying that when
she was being interviewed that she was
asked like are you uncomfortable with
nudity you might just be one of those
people that are like cool or whatever
he's like I'm busy on a [ __ ] care
like take yeah yeah but he's not
respecting the people that people would
feel he thinks he's so smart and he's
like so understands the world no like no
one else's feelings they're like
everyone else's feelings are small and
where they're not
evolved yet yeah maybe he has that like
godlike syndrome you know and if that's
the case that's fine but just like hire
a personal assistant that's always there
when you're like we're writing the
personal assistant oh the personal
that's there and then if that's the case
then you make her sighs his wife
commented on any of the fun they do have
NDA's and stuff so I'm not sure but
these wouldn't she be concerned so there
was this one other person that came
forward and said like oh we had a
consensual affair and that once the
first wife found out about it that she
was immediately fired and then that she
was told that you have grounds to to sue
this guy for unlawful what is it like
termination unlawful termination and
then that she said like no he's too
scary and rich and powerful I don't want
to go up against him they that's the
only wife comment that I read but yeah I
mean it's hilarious
yeah he's very rich and he ki has power
because he's rich and he has a lot of
influence and that cuz that's his whole
business is influenced so that's why I'm
like reserving judgment cuz you it could
be that he did that but I just don't
feel like there's enough information to
make like an informed opinion yeah I
think just stand in the middle for right
now yeah cuz if you watch if you watch
his Netflix special Steve loves the
clown this guy he always throws like
Anthony Tony Robin references out there
and like jokes about it and so he was
didn't want to watch this special and I
was watching it cuz I was I was curious
about how his live events actually are
cuz I've heard them on audio but I'd
never seen one and and I know a lot of
friends that have gone and so I wanted
to see it and Steve ended up watching it
with me and by the end of it he was like
I like this guy
I actually agree was a lot of things he
says and so it's Dee
is pretty critical about the elite
doesn't really like very many people
what you'll see whatever comes out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]